hello and welcome once again to Android
design and action
today's episode is actually a slightly
different format this is a pre-recorded
version of the show because we have a
special guest here today so before we
introduce everybody my name is Roman
Nurik I'm your host we're also joined by
Nick butcher over in London and like we
mentioned before we're joined today by a
special guest hi I'm Alex Webb work
designer on the Android team very happy
to be here and today we're gonna be
talking about notifications and the
design process and Alex will be leading
the way with a bunch of slides Before we
jump in Alex do you want to introduce
yourself say a few words about what
you're doing yeah sure thing so I work
on you know sort of the Android system
and platforms so things like
notifications obviously the topic of
this show today intense launcher you
know just sort of the base base
interface of the the OS itself awesome
and your do you focus primarily on
interaction design visual design or
would you say you have a specialty in
any of those um the primarily
interaction it's some visual direction
but yeah mostly interactive designer
awesome okay and hopefully a lot of
people have seen the excellent Google
i/o presentation that you gave with
Kristian Robertson as well on and design
for engineers I've particularly enjoyed
that and have craved a lot of your lines
that you use and many of my
presentations thanks you can plug my
other video yeah we keep watching this
and then when you're done watching this
be sure to check out advanced design for
engineering from i/o 2012 yeah okay so
with that should we jump into the the
slides about notifications and yeah
definitely so notifications and you dive
into this the first thing I wanna talk
about is the psychology concept of flow
flows basically it's it's kind of hard
to describe and you can read the
Wikipedia article about it if that helps
but it's best to just sort of think
about times you've experienced it so
it's when sort of everything fades away
and you're just really focused intently
on something you're creating so like if
you're a musician you're not thinking
about the musical instrument that you're
playing or you know even playing video
games
yeah you don't think about the
controller that you're holding the
controller just sort of fades away and
you also get into the state with
computing a lot where you're I'm sort of
engaged in what you're doing
we're with the mobile device you're out
in the world engaged and what can
destroy flow is interruptions and
notifications are kind of fundamentally
interruptive so flows a really good
state for people to be in and it's a
little bit dangerous to be sort of
constantly pulling them out of that the
main problem there is they're just not
going to be as effective
so if flow is proposed by psychologists
Chiklis Mejia and it's you know
characterized by this sort of complete
and absorption of what you're doing this
is kind of like a feeling of I'm in the
zone like kind of like yeah it's like
exactly what it is okay so I think
what's what's important to think about
is sort of the users attention stream is
this sort of precious resource that
needs to be protected mhm and yeah
especially like on tablets is sort of
larger format devices they're possibly
reading a book you know although
effectively a lot of full screen apps
are now going sort of you know
lights-out mode where people aren't
going to be as which later often but
something of immersiveness right like
you're immersed in the content and what
you're doing yeah so I think it's really
important to think about you know
assuming the user is immersed is it
worthwhile to interrupt them with the
notification that your applications
about to generate sometimes it is so if
it's use as a sort of you know developer
analogy basically what you're doing is
you're kind of blocking the user thread
like literally the users brand like you
are blocking that they're sort of
cognitive flow momentarily to deliver
your notifications so do you want to
block that thread so three rules for
creating notifications the first one is
doesn't involve another person I'm so
like a real-time chat yeah is there
someone or a hangout or something is
there someone sitting there waiting for
you so you need to get the person's
attention because yeah this other person
is actually waiting on them it's kind of
like is another thread waiting on you
exactly right another very important
human thread
it's like waiting for you so that's the
first one is the time-sensitive you know
block something out of your calendar
that events gonna end you need to get to
it yeah and that's you know sort of one
of the reasons why you'd want to deliver
a notification and then finally is it
you know something that the user is
specifically requested it's like an
alarm doesn't involve another person it
is time-sensitive and it's something the
user said so is this something with user
said you know please remind me at this
moment or if this happens then of course
that's totally okay to barge in a lot of
notifications on Android don't follow
these three rules and that's not good um
we we would love to see applications put
sort of more thought and care and sort
of planning into if a notifications
worthwhile or not and we have some new
capabilities especially with the low
priority notifications where you can
your application can generate
notification and put it in the shade so
when the user goes in there they see it
but it's not something that's going to
cause the phone to vibrate and buzz or
to LED to illuminate so it's not gonna
actively grab the users attention this
is gonna be there in case they go and
check so it's kind of that notifications
kind of along for the ride when another
notification does actually ping you then
they can consume all of them and yeah by
clustering them together and we've we've
talked about this a little bit on the
showi I think we kind of called them
opportunistic notifications right if you
have the opportunity if the users
already in the process of checking you
know what's what's going on then you
know give them that information an
example of this would be Google now is
weather right I think the default
weather is a low priority notification
so it only shows up if you already
expanded the notification chain right so
actually all of Google now notifications
are low priority with the exception of
time to leave so if we are monitoring
traffic and we realize that you really
need to leave soon because traffic is
heavy and the only way you're going to
arrive on time
is if you take off right now then we go
ahead and interrupt but that's actually
the only case of Google Google now doing
an interrupted notification and all of
the others are and we're calling them
and be at notifications and sort of
notion of the you know they're just
there but yeah
I think it's I think low prior low
priority is the official name yeah yeah
so if you're if you're a developer and
you're figuring out how to do this it's
actually extremely easy luckily if
you're using the notification compat
class all you need to do is just pass in
a priority of I think is partied out low
or there's a constant value for it and
the good thing is that if you're this
actually is only supported on a jelly
bean and above but if you're on earlier
versions of the platform you'll actually
see an interrupted notification it's
kind of like you know there's no way to
show notification in the expanded state
that that's not also in the collapsed at
an earlier versions but you will benefit
from the new kind of better more correct
behavior on newer devices without having
to do any sort of backward compatibility
code since that's already done for you
it's worth saying that there's other
priorities even lower while low is the
only one that'll you know not interrupt
the user I do believe we use the
priority to order the list of
notifications right so I think they have
saying which is the extremely high
priority or you know you can recognize
that your notifications just qualify for
the rules but isn't the most important
thing in the user's world then you can
set something between low and Max
there's some intermediate levels you can
really hinter the user so that they have
they find that that lists more useful
when it's sorted yeah and don't just set
it to max because as you want your a
notification to be above all the other
applications
yeah I think the one major takeaway so
far is just be mindful of what the user
wants right it don't like your your
application and I think a Adam Powell
and the framework team uses an analogy
really well you're a guest in the users
house right the users house the device
you know you're a guest there if you're
an application since telling the device
be mindful and be respectful you don't
want to barge them and bombard them with
imagine your notification is an airhorn
and after the users you know suddenly
startled by it then you have to pack
that up with interesting information
that they care about and find relevant
they say thank you for sounding that
airhorn right then maybe when you're
developing you can set a custom
notification ringtone or just a test
whether you really think you are
interrupting at the right time yeah or
we just changed the API to the name it
interrupts the user and then people will
yeah it will be more mindful like a
notification manager that interrupts
yeah
piss off the yeah and why it is worth
noting that users can silence your
notification or silence your application
from generating any notifications they
can also uninstall your application if
it's becoming overly annoying so beyond
just it being the right thing to do
there are good reasons to not annoy the
user through notifications and that's
especially true of notifications that
are trying to like solicit positive
reviews in the store I would love to see
a study if that actually results in more
negative reviews per time I I would
assume that that could be likely yeah
yeah yeah we definitely some best
practices on you know when to solicit
reviews and and what not to do
especially I cannot test for five stars
of these things like that but certainly
I mean notifications are they're really
exciting that's more timely like if you
want to ask the user for review if if
there's any you know place to put it
it's not gonna be an identification
probably gonna be somewhere deep within
your app and either help or but so
somewhere that they're kind of already
exploring you know more about your app
and potentially they want to give you
feedback yeah or I mean normally after
I've had a good outcome I find as well
right just do it you know if the first
launch whatever yeah
yeah they should have at least had a
chance to use it I would say probably
should never ask for a review but if you
are going to at least do it inside your
application not while they're using
another application right I guess
another important thing to note is
correct usage of toasts so a toast
should be a direct response to a user
action usually there's a nice little
confirmation so like you know message
sent or item archived to these types of
things where you're hitting a button and
then it's just kind of immediately
mirroring back like dip got it do not
generate a toast when your application
doesn't have focus
I remember we talked about this when we
were working in the style guide a while
ago and this is one of the big things
one of the biggest pet peeves right it
was it is so I have a couple of
different banking applications installed
on my phone I'll be using something else
and just in the middle of nowhere I'll
get a toast that says your banking
session has ended and I don't even know
which application is responsible is it
thank your bank yeah I mean because I
tend to open them and you know at the
same time so like not only do I like
it's I can't even like contact them to
be like what guys what's wrong
so really not helpful to show toast at
an hour sort of the reason we have a
whole notification shade and
notification manager and all this is to
have that that nice place for your
message also important not to treat
notifications as a kind of almost like
error log I know there's there's some
note applications where you know it'll
generate notification that says like
note was saved to the cloud mm-hmm it's
like great that's so happy for ya
yeah I was actually off doing something
else right I just left but I'm glad you
took care of that and then told me about
it so obviously anything is just sort of
your app managing itself I would even
say take this as far as we should be
notifying people about software updates
something we're working on which is yeah
Android itself not following that rule
but yeah it should involve other people
should be time sensitive where should be
something user specifically requested
awesome yeah very very good general
advice and just on the topic of
notifications while we're on it we also
have a design pattern documented on
developer.android.com slash design that
talks about you know lots of different
situations where you should show
notifications and in addition if you're
we touched a little bit on help and
things like that there's also a pattern
that talks about help and tutorials not
exactly related to notifications but
still definitely stuff that you should
read yeah
actually move on to yeah I can but
design process let's do it
alright design workflow so we thought
this would be a fun topic to go into you
just sort of talked about some of the
the ways that design teams at Google
have their workflow which is likely
almost the same as everywhere else
usually this stuff is pretty standard
but talk about sort of the the various
artifacts that we create the reasons we
create them sort of how they what
purpose they serve at each stage of the
process start running through that so
the example we use is Google now I got a
chance to be one of the designers on
Google now
which is very widely recognized and you
know very widely recognized as a really
really kind of awesome design overall
and a lot of folks have been looking at
that as kind of you know inspiration
taking inspiration from it so just
personally you know I want to applaud
you guys in the design team for building
an awesome product thank you it was a
super talented team they got to work on
it so we'll give you kind of a
behind-the-scenes look sort of like
movie special features what it looked
like before it was awesome as it was
being created I always looked awesome
well we'll see so here's actually some
of the very first sketches of Google now
up on a white board and as you can see
not great at drawing perfect rectangles
but what what's great about sketches is
for soliciting really high level
feedback so when you show someone just a
bunch of sort of markings on a white
board like this they're immediately
engaged in the idea and coming up with
their own ideas and providing feedback
on the level of they feel like like it's
appropriate to provide feedback to the
station whereas if you show someone you
know it's like perfectly rendered high
fidelity mock-up they'll start
commenting on really minor details but
they won't be like actually that's a bad
idea like you shouldn't be doing this at
all or um you know have you thought
about these other things that are you
know slightly related so it's important
to sort of scale the fidelity of the
mock-ups you're creating with the the
type of engagement you want from the
people you're showing them to so
obviously at this point we were just
trying to generate ideas on if we had
this sort of proactive software that was
pulling information for you what
information would a pool would be
interesting so we you know we were kind
of going through various actions you
could have on the cards and the types of
cards and actually a lot of the stuff
ended up shipping I think everything on
this second product which is awesome
stages right not everything rolled out
in the very first version but yeah yeah
no this was all in the first version all
right and the guy the flight
notifications yeah we didn't have
boarding passes okay yeah yeah so
there's that your very first sketch of
Google now from then we quickly sort of
staffed up the design team had more
people working on it and here's kind of
image of the the sort of war room we had
as we were quickly posting stuff up on
the wall for review so again it's that
sort of sketch level there's some more
higher fidelity things here that are
exploring visual design but the the sort
of purpose here is to go as broad as
possible instead of a steep responsible
explore as many ideas as you can and you
know you're you're trying to sort of
solicit feedback from people and be
creative so not being overly critical of
any ideas you know to sort of shut
brainstorming down but saying oh that's
cool but have you tried this and I was
kind of you know redirecting if you're
trying to steer things in particular do
a quick question I mean at this stage
are you thinking about layout I mean it
so in the earlier stage you're probably
thinking a little bit about Leia but
more about you know the the
functionality the the actual product
itself like what will the user be able
to get out of this one of their benefits
you know what are the different things
they can do but at this stage are you
starting to think about layout yet and
and potentially even I guess like the
pixels themselves probably not right so
I know a lot of the the stages the
visual designers we're just starting to
think about what if it you know we were
doing automatic layout based on the
content and kind of taking the overall
spirit of what the application was about
and applying that to kind of there's yes
so that was a little bit different than
normal
the the layout is obviously we you can't
not have a layout it's writing one of
these we're not trying to like these
mock-ups yeah I guess I'm trying to get
out is like are you thinking about all
the different situations for layout
because I'm you know as an Android
developer you have to think about you
know how does this look on a tablet how
does it oh yeah in portrait landscape at
this point we were just purely doing
phones and we figured we
you'll travel later your tablet ended up
just being sort of multiple columns very
hard so I mean in some ways we we still
kind of dodged that I mean it's an
effective layout for the device but it
wasn't it didn't provide a lot of custom
work for us sure I just do that layout
so yeah so we're still generating ideas
next up would be wireframes we actually
we were kind of short on time with us of
totally skipped wireframes here's my
approximation of a wireframe this is
actually more higher fidelity than you
would have yeah so then we kind of you
know to full fidelity mock-ups these
were actually created for a like a Larry
Page review and you know at that point
you're sort of presenting the full
vision of the application for feedback
you're saying yeah we feel a lot of
thought into this this is sort of how we
imagined it and you're trying to get
feedback on sort of fine details and
also kind of the spirit of the thing as
a whole as opposed to feedback you know
specifically on yeah these sort of you
know the finer things like layout right
so I you know it's you're giving them
what could potentially be pixel perfect
mocks he's ended up being very different
from what we actually shipped but they
were at least at the time pixel perfect
to really help them visualize what this
thing's gonna be about but I guess like
maybe because because it was you know
review for executives for somebody
that's kind of higher up you want to
make sure that they are fully kind of
they're seeing the actual vision maybe
not like you know sketches you don't
show sketches to like a c-level person
I'm guessing right I well I I mean it
always depends I guess are on on the
executive and sort of how they're
engaged in the product but I think it's
it's often easier for people to get
excited about something that that looks
real so it and it's also it communicates
sort of the amount of work and thought
that you've put into it when you dive to
sort of fill fidelity mock-ups at that
stage and it lets you sort of test
certain boundaries like the the
contextual header and Google now is
definitely something new and here we
were actually using photographs that
were sort of interested
what feedback that was going to serve
generate and we weren't even at the time
we weren't super comfortable with
photographs but we wanted to put those
into the full fidelity mock-ups just
kind of you know push that boundary of
what we'd be doing with Google brand so
then obviously you want to use full
fidelity for sort of visual explorations
so here we have kind of the full range
of a photograph with a filter applied to
it and then some sort of extremely sort
of block imagery very sort of field
generator yeah at the bottom here with
you know the most simplistic of bridges
which is actually pretty ridiculous okay
that way we're you know just trying to
see the range versus you know something
more like this so we spent a lot of time
on this contextual header one of our
super talented visual designers created
the sort of sequence where here we have
really kind of abstract art I loved
these I I actually kind of like this
direction better than yeah there's very
very talented and yeah here it was a
mixture of time and day and whether
that's supposed to place we ended up
focusing on place because we felt that
people often have this kind of
connection to where they live and this
is sort of you know almost you know
pride in their hometown and so we're
we're kind of urging that also when
you're traveling it's really neat to see
the new headers so we dropped it's just
the the purely abstract but I thought
these were just absolutely beautiful
even more abstract we thought it was
those much before it was sort of mr.
more abstract with some items in the
background of place and then we started
exploring this notion of cities in San
Francisco being shown here and some one
of Seattle here's you know that same
style sort of a country town
and then just yeah sort of that nature
one was kind of triggering the next as
we would get these posted up on the wall
and you know sort of talk about you know
what it conveys and how people are gonna
feel as they see it so then the sprout a
little bit closer to where we landed was
sort of a little bit more detail but
still illustrative and then here's where
we're filming in New York today so I
thought I'd show one of the early New
York ones
yeah when these sort of strong shadows
which we see a lot in a lot of Google's
design work
yeah the 45-degree angle yeah
which experiment with the kind of the
holiday style text input books as well
mm-hmm oh yeah it is and we ended up
dropping that because it didn't quite
have the the sort of visual hierarchy
that we were looking for especially
about controlling the background it was
it was falling out but yeah this was the
one that we kind of sold as the
direction we really liked and then from
there it was you know iterating on you
know going out and creating all the
cities here we have London me yeah New
York or San Francisco and you know all
the different times of day and just I
personally loved all their pallets I
mean to me the if you were to drop these
into something like you know cooler data
they'll be that commerce or even dribble
you know we they give you a kind of a
color range or like if you upload a
photo or upload a design they kind of
give you the general color scheme I feel
like these if you were to import those
they would result in some of the best
color palettes I just personally am in
love with especially the San Francisco
one yeah and the ones at night I was
really loved its New York one at night
with the airplane many permutations of
them have had as you ended up generating
so there's there's actually quite a few
more than this we're doing them over
time and staging out cities we started
targeting we were trying to get all the
cities by population for a while and
then realized we weren't getting some of
the the text centers so those got kind
of accelerated include those it's over
time you'll see more and more cities so
we also we actually do use some filters
on the photograph
in google now just we could have more
coverage at launch because these
obviously take some time to make but
this was sort of the art style that we I
love the ambition of it as well that
yeah we're gonna provide a localized
header for every major city yeah I know
which a lot of people were kind of
critical of and yeah I was trying to
make argument well it's a finite set I
mean reckoned but I think it'd convey
something about a putt right this is
Google and there's an element of magic
and you know Google boils oceans and
does these crazy big tusks and I think
you know it resonates with Google's
image and what we're trying to do if now
I think very very well yeah I guess it's
also actually important to talk about so
you know higher level why are we doing
all of this we we wanted to be sure that
when you went into the application you
understood that it was contextual and
having the header change over time made
sort of every part even the artwork
contextual and have a change based off
of your location so it became this sort
of immediate sort of visual affordance
of oh these cards really are alive
they're about what's happening right now
and right here so it was able to set
that tone whereas Google Calm it's it's
white it's kind of about you know the
infinite possibilities of finding
anything this is you know obviously you
can still do a search but it's also sort
of we've we've created the search based
off of your current context so we felt
that that was sort of helpful to set the
users expectations of what the
application would do right off the bat
with the header even the motion graphics
design was was done to convey that
though the notion of the cards dealing
in where you see them deal immediately
it helps establish this mental model of
these were just created for you based on
what's happening right now
also we one of the reasons I was
focusing on a card metaphor was it can
kind of help with expectations of you
know like when you're playing cards this
may or may not be a good hand
thankfully the quality has been great
now in the beginning it wasn't so the
managing expectations yeah like I could
cards this time it's so yeah so that but
it's worth noting that in addition to
all the visual design I'm showing here
there was a lot of motion graphics
that went into google now actually had a
dedicated motion graphics designer who
was working on cards dealing in the the
field expanding you know the the
microphone radiating and the sort of
circles coming off with a microphone as
an indication of appear speaking too
loud or not which i thought was really
interesting oh wow
so like one of the problems with speech
recognition is for some reason people
well they assume the accuracy is not
gonna be great it's kind of naturally
just kind of start shouting oh yeah my
parents are yeah I think everyone's
parents yeah and the problem that is
then you start blowing out the
microphone so actually the recognition
is much worse because if you can't even
get a good signal yes we wanted
something to sort of show no too loud so
it actually hits sort of this outer
radius and turns red if you believe it
does that was the design at least I need
to go back and make sure we finish that
but yeah they have that kind of media
feedback and have it feel alive so kind
of continuing on with slides here we'll
ask more about motion graphics in oh
yeah sure thing well I mean motion
graphic also kind of comes into play in
the this is sort of the the most static
way of describing but here's the flow
you're basically trying to visualize the
sequence of steps these are useful for
knowing kind of you know or what your
key frames are in terms of you need to
animate from here to here and I have no
idea how to do that which is actually
not the best way of framing it to motion
graphics designers Mordo I said oh yeah
don't you want to evoke and what you're
trying to communicate with the graphics
but yeah but flows are also really
useful for just sort of understanding
the the sort of temporal complexity of
your application which is it's important
to get it up on the board and look at it
saying is it actually too difficult to
get from from this location sits a
little location there's too many
navigation steps it's going to take
these or too much time people often
think about complexity in terms of the
number of objects on screen but if you
make things simple simply by introducing
navigational steps you've really just
kind of shifted your complexity into a
different type of complexity so it's
really good to look at the sequences so
you can see temporal complexity we also
then sort of final stages red lines
just for communicating sort of specific
values colors padding things like this
because you want everything to be pixel
perfect and perfect alignment this was
actually a much earlier design of Google
now the red line but this is SHS we were
moving on to engineering this was the
red line we used right then this is
actually something that that's a very
important tool for designers to
communicate with developers right so as
a developer you generally you know look
at it you may look at a pixel perfect
and they say okay I need to roughly
approximate this so let me just make
this like three dips or four dips and
that looks about right and and let me
actually just do this so as a designer I
mean if you're if you're communicating
and working with developers make sure to
give them these these piece of
information and another may just want to
add in here is make sure to note what
should stretch what should be fixed you
know what is responsive almost put in
like if it requires text like a text
description like this should stay fixed
and so on and so forth make sure to
include that that's one of the most
important tools I think for for
communicating between designers and
developers yeah yeah similar kind of
techniques for doing motion like do you
like I don't know how you'd how you
would document that you wanted to
animate in a certain way would you just
use the keyframe type snapshots or do
you have like a similar technique to
read lines for saying this should move
like this or you know we don't we do it
all with hand gestures which is not
nearly as exact as if we had a red line
but often the motion graphics designer
they're sort of the I mean you're
generating the videos that can then be
used you know to convert to the final
animations so from those you can extract
you know timing and that so I mean it'd
be somewhere to like a sub red line a
developer going into Photoshop and
actually measuring sentences and that
you have to like view the properties and
after-effects and it's some cases of me
if you have the resources you could also
probably you know spend some time to
prototype something you know I think I
don't know if we have any prototype
engineers but I know that some companies
actually have folks that don't even
build the software the final shipping
software but they will build a prototype
that roughly approximates the you know
the general behaviors interactions and
motion
potentially using you know the actual
tools you'll be using to build the app
or using things like you know processing
that Jas or or even HTML Javascript
something that's kind of really easy and
lightweight and easy to iterate on those
tools can be very useful for again
communicating that idea mm-hmm yeah and
then yeah creating latent process and
commuting or only in the process you're
just focusing on you know how do you
want to sort of set the stage of your
application how does it immediately
present itself what do you want the
users attention to focus on because much
like dinosaurs you know t-rex is I don't
you know seeing motion like or I will be
drawn to anything that's animating so as
you're doing the motion graphics design
is again about the users attention you
know what you're notifying them of at in
that moment in time of what on what on
screen you want them to fixate on how
you want to sort of draw their attention
to something and it's another case of
like don't animate needlessly don't
animate just for a visual flair and
right have it have a purpose a story of
your animation a reason you want users
to focus on something so yeah I mean
like in Google now you know when you say
Google it goes into microphone mode so
we wanted people you know obviously you
might just say Google while looking at
it's the the search field you know
stretches down so you can see sort of
what you acted on yeah as you're going
into the mode obviously when you tap it
you don't need to communicate that as
much as you literally touched it but for
the voice input I thought that was
really effective way of I'm telling that
story of the search field has become the
microphone input so even though it's not
taking test entry at that point you're
still speaking to this object so that's
awesome
yes sort of the level of sort of
analysis you have to do in terms of the
motion graphics and and crafting that
story about how the application behaves
awesome yeah so
let's move on to some final social
engineering tips for as you are showing
your mock-ups so the one of the first
things that I found it's really
effective is you want sort of the
feeling to be in very collaborative as
you're showing these to various
engineers and project managers and
marketing people you're working with so
one of the easiest things you can do is
showing your work live in the
application used to create it so as
people are generating feedback you're
adding notes you're making changes so it
feels like it's this sort of fluid
living document as opposed to like
printing it out and you know posting it
up on the wall and you know having
everyone's kind of look at it or even
just projecting it but it's like a
flattened PDF or something where it
feels more finalized progress like
actual progress is being made right
there in that moment yeah exactly and
like not only are you listening to them
but like their their input is being like
you know like directly influencing so
it's not like pair designing in a way
sort of pair programming or if you do
print your work out you know set it at a
table flat on the table have you know
both people sitting there with pens kind
of marking up so it feels like it's very
sort of collaborative and it's important
to sort of yeah as you're defending you
know reasons that you did something or
try not to have the design yet be
changed in particular way
don't you know say oh well I'm the
designer or that's my opinion
yeah act like back it up with specific
design principles with like actual
reasons that are irrefutable on why it
needs to be that way it's tough because
you know some things are so very you
know subjective some things are just
like I have this intuition I can't
explain it but definitely you know big
part of the communication processes make
is articulating what you're thinking
yeah even if it feels often it's not
subjective like there is there are
actual reasons why something should
should be a certain way you know
underlying cognitive science and yeah
design principles and like or even just
existing user studies if you even have
done a user study on it yourself there
are previous user studies so point to
the same results that you can anticipate
so I that that's very important to sort
of make sure that you're you're sort of
you're your take on the design is kind
of dripping in science because if it's
just my opinion versus your opinion
you could just you know continue
debating forever yet like engineers
don't debate oh I think it should crash
more you know all right you should be
slower and you know the design does have
these these fun about principles and
various usability heuristics things that
we've learned through years of testing
on how people are gonna behave what
they're gonna focus on if they're going
to be annoyed by how many notifications
you're having engine is creating this is
probably a good moment to say that you
know the design guidelines that we have
on developer the edge of the complex
design I mean a lot of that is is taking
into account all these studies that
we've done all these kind of things that
we have that you guys have had in your
minds for a while and putting it down on
paper not necessarily you know saying
that these are the only things you
should be doing but a lot of that is
driven by these these heuristics is your
emotion yeah obviously provides great
guidance good plug just said that as
well so yeah let's let's move on to
questions quickly yeah and before we
move that's questions are running a
little low on time but I just wanted to
say thanks for sharing all that
information that's a lot of enlightening
stuff I definitely learned a lot in the
past 20 or 30 minutes all right so that
was I was a whopping 30 plus minute
episode thanks again Alex for joining
Rome thanks for every all right so we'll
see you guys next time here on Android
design in action as always I'm Roman
Nurik
Alex 100 from Nick butcher all right you
guys later see hi how do you